thank you very much Kevin I'm very
grateful for the invitation to come here
it's a fantastic on a wonderful
University fantastic campus utiful
buildings and then you get the school of
architecture and in that sort of theme I
think therefore it's okay from
economists to be talking about ecology
so I want to talk about this thing
called the National ecosystem assessment
I want you to try and relax and just
enjoy it so everything that i'm going to
show you is available I've given this
slide to kavita and she's put it put it
up on your website so just relax don't
worry about it if there's any detail
just go to those papers okay so what's
the objective of this talk and indeed of
the whole undertaking that is the
ecosystem service approach why it's just
really to improve decision-making there
is one big assumption everybody kind of
glosses over this Steve Pulaski I think
the most honest exam iteration of it to
a couple of days ago and that is that we
should make decisions which optimize
present and future human values of
course the emphasis theories on the
humid values I'm not going to dwell too
much on that I'm sure you've thought
about the implications of that
throughout the course seems to me that
the characteristics of a good egg system
service decision-making system actually
boil down to just three you need sound
silence you need sound valuation and you
also need sound costing and costing may
not be the same as valuation and I'll
come on to that right at the end of the
talk so when it go through all three of
these but I want to start with some
context and the UK context is
particularly interesting because we they
actually take it seriously there they
really do make decisions on the basis of
the ecosystem service approach
and on valuations of ecosystem services
they've got one of the longest histories
of applying it you can see the variety
of applications there so taxis for
landfill for cars regulation of wetlands
first and then nearly all natural areas
now recreation both urban and rural
being planned using values climate
policy being driven by values so if you
are interested the UK is a very good
place to come and do this for real and I
will say brief advert I have a job
available right now for somebody who's
really bright really smart quantitative
you're working with a group with
phenomenal resources both monetary and
intellectual but unfortunately i'd have
to be your boss but the others of them
they're really smart they took things
like thee that when i say they UK
government took things like the MEA
millennium ecosystem assessment very
seriously and decided to basically go
out and do one for the UK which is a
good idea because you get an immediate
advantage that you've got much better
data when you restrict it to a smaller
area but also an area where data has
been gathered for a very long time the
ne ne a was delivered this summer it was
actually written all the way through in
conjunction with policymakers and it was
no coincidence that was completely timed
that a week later the government's new
environmental policy came out and
basically said yes this is what we're
going to do so they're actually doing it
now conceptual framework I'm sure you
know a lot about this but it's not
looking at total values I think
environmental accounting is a very
interesting undertaking but it's very
difficult to actually make policy
choices with environmental accounting so
instead we're looking at marginal
changes and those changes driven by lots
of forces you can see them up there
and they impinge upon different types of
capital the sort of things that Steve
Pulaski was talking about natural
capital and other capital and these
combined together natural capital
deliver Zeke system services combining
with other capital to give us Goods and
of course buy goods I don't just mean
those things that are in shops and
stores I also mean those non market
goods which deliver values now two types
of values here it's one over here
collective values I don't know much
about that and I'm not going to pretend
to but there was an attempt to look at
whatever they are I'm going to stick to
the normal sort of economic side of it
but those values feed into the
governance process and evaluation
exercise is undertaken that valuation is
increasingly sensitive to things like
scale place and time because all of
those things are going to change values
values for everything else change over
time values change according to what
place you're in and that's also true of
environmental values and you'll see that
the approach that we develop through the
NEA is highly spatially sensitive it's
also temporarily sensitive this
information goes out into decisions
they're implemented some very
interesting work going on on the
implementation of these evaluations I'll
only be able to talk about it briefly in
the time available but that provides
another impetus back to a new driver of
the system so it keeps evolving around
this talk is going to look mainly at
that bit up there the relationship
between natural and other types of
capital producing Goods and producing
values so I said that the first thing
that you need for good ich system
service decision-making is sound science
and the National each system assessment
employed no less than six hundred
scientists this is probably I don't know
if it's the biggest project in the world
but it's one of the biggest projects
certainly in Europe that's ever been
undertaken
and they over two year period looked at
what is happening and what else what has
been happening over the last 50 years in
trends of ecosystem services now they
try to summarize it in one single
diagram which is a bit scary it's this
diagram here but actually I think it was
a valid attempt what they tried to do is
say well you know you can decompose the
UK into a whole set of habitats and you
can look at the various values that
these generate and therefore each sale
tells you about how important a given
habitat is to a given service so
obviously in close farmland is very
important for crops that's way it's
shaded dark the arrows are the things
that are interesting though they tell
you about the trend in that service is
it going up is it going down do we not
know it whatever and so obviously with
that particular example it's going
firmly up because food productivity has
expanded over time quite dramatically
this was looking at the period from the
end of the Second World War onwards we
can simplify that just in a few bullet
points and basically say that since the
end of the war there's been a big
increase in provisioning but there's
been decreases in lots of other
ecosystem services over the last 10 to
20 years there have been discernible
changes in the path of each system
service delivery some services still
declining rapidly some of them beginning
to show a reduction in the rate of
decline partly as a result of various
regulations others actually beginning to
improve but overall by 2010 we've got a
status situation where about thirty five
percent are still declining some from
very low levels and about twenty percent
are improving the remainder constant or
unclear so there is a mass
report if you want to get it that that
first page shows you where to download
it you can get the one-page version the
seven-page version the 50-page version
or the 2,000 page version so you know
whatever time frame you've got it will
fit in but let's now move on to the
valuation side these are the services
that were identified for valuation and
all of these we're valued money values
were attached to all of these how was
this done I know you've had some
lectures on this so I'll be brief some
of them have market prices some of these
market prices can't be used unadjusted
because they're distorted so for example
food prices particularly in Europe are
distorted by something called a common
agricultural policy so you have to
adjust to try and get the underlying
value out of that but nevertheless you
could start off with the market prices
and then do that adjustment other things
were valued by looking at their
contribution to output so there's quite
a big effort looking at for example
pollination services and seeing to what
extent these actually contributed to
food production and thereby finding a
valuation for that service other things
were valued by looking at the costs that
were avoided by these services so for
example pollution remediation for
example I notice you've got some reed
beds out there I don't think they're
being used for this but certainly in the
UK reed beds are increasingly being used
to clean up water contamination of
course that is providing a service that
otherwise would be very costly it's not
a perfect way to value things but it
gives you something to put in the
account sheet a better way of valuing
thing is to look at observe behavior
reveal behavior and here you can look at
things like recreation you can look at
how far people are prepared to travel to
different sorts of resources the cost
that they're prepared to incur
with regard to that another approach you
can look at health spur choises and the
relationship with environmental quality
and finally you can ask people questions
stated preferences I've done stated
preference research for a long time and
as a result of that we didn't use this
very much got to keep up we've had we
came up with loads and loads of values
absolutely loads this is just the start
of a table that just goes on and on and
on we tried to come up with marginal
values and also to use them at mostly is
we were very interested in trying to get
melt marginal value functions if
possible rather than constants because
you would expect marginal values to
change as the provision of a good
changes and then we try to work out when
I say totals I'm talk about total totals
of changes from a baseline under a
different a set of different scenarios
I'm going to illustrate some of the
procedures that we did by looking at
those scenarios here they are six
scenarios there was actually each one of
them is doubled because each one
operates for a lower mission and a high
emission variant you can see from the
names the sort of things that these
scenarios look at now these scenarios
will come word arrived for a process
that he's not the way I'd have done it
but falling it was a political science
approach talking to decision-makers
about the sort of future worlds that
they were interested in or that they
were worried in and coming up with a set
of functions which would end up with
which would be consequent from those
different policies we're going to look
in particular at two of them one's
called nature at work
where there's a priority to enhance
ecosystem services and the other one
world market where there's unfettered
economic growth and trade liberalisation
okay how do we then illustrate what
happens under these different scenarios
we're going to look at a set of
different values and I've chosen these
out of the long list of values to
illustrate some different cases so we're
looking at agricultural output values as
an example of a market price good
greenhouse gas emissions as an example
of a non-market good which almost
certainly has constant marginal values
you could for example you could have
forests the whole of Britain and it
would store or a fair amount of carbon
but it wouldn't really change the rate
of global warming to the extent that the
marginal value of sequestering a further
ton of carbon would really change that
might that much so you can affect say
these are current constant marginal
values recreation a rural non-market
good with very clearly demolish
diminishing marginal value so you know
if I put a wood at the back of the
department's here that will generate
some non market value but if I put a
second would next to it it's probably
not going to generate any extra value at
all so the marginal values are going to
go down pretty fast same sort of thing
applies to urban green space amenity
although of course it's a particular
interest because of the proximity to
large numbers of people and finally I'm
going to focus the last part of my talk
all on biodiversity because what do you
do when you don't believe the values
that people come up with so demonstrate
methodology and give you the messages
start off with that first one
agriculture well the first thing to
think about agriculture is that it's the
consequence of a whole variety of
different drivers there are 0
see drivers there are market drivers
this technology and there's
cross-sectional and temporal
environmental drivers the
cross-sectional ones are really captured
really well in a country like Britain
although it's a really small country
compared to the u.s. it's got a very
heterogeneous landscape got some really
good wheat lands we've got some
absolutely rubbish rocks basically that
you can't grow anything on a great
diversity we've got a lot of places that
are extremely wet and cold we've got
some other places that are less wet and
cold but not amazing unfortunately don't
have quite the range that you've got
across the whole of the US but you know
there's some good variation there you
need a lot of data to do this and you
have to build models that are inherently
spatial and the great thing about
working in the UK and why really well
qualified members of the audience shins
considerate doing exactly that is that
there is phenomenal data resources which
go back longer than probably any other
country in the world now we actually
only use data back to the 1960s but
nevertheless this was data that was
gathered every two kilometers there's
200 records taken right across the whole
of Great Britain we also got hold on
50,000 farm years of business data and
you stick these all together and you've
got a hell of a lot of information about
what farmers are actually doing you can
combine that with a lot of again highly
spatially referenced data on the
environment how it varies temporarily
and spatially cross-sectionally policy
which our EU policy makers have very
kindly decided will be an almost perfect
economics experiment because they keep
changing their mind and sometimes
they'll apply policies in one place and
not in another
that's just just what you need and of
course over that period since the 60s
you've got a lot of change in input
prices and output prices the model it's
a structural model so it's very nice
theoretically compatible estimated using
some nice econometrics it's all there if
you want to find out about it I'm going
to use a very simplified version of it
you basically take a profit function you
stick it through duality theory and you
come up with production functions
example serials so the area of cereals
within any two kilometre block is a
function of lots of things it's a
function of economic market pressures
the price of cereals nice and positive
there the price of fertilizers nice and
negative just what you'd expect policy
has a big impact because they keep
saying to farmers grow more wait no
don't grow more weight grow more weight
again and so every time they do this it
has big impact on farmers fact we found
some very nice lagged effects farmers
actually respond faster nail to prices
than they do to policy and I think it's
a real consequence of the fact that you
don't know if that probably so they're
actually going to stay around very long
and lots of environmental stuff and
there's something that I want to pick
out for you these down here degree days
that's basically a measure of
temperature during the growing season
and this is rainfall measure well of
precipitation thank God I could think of
a different word over the season why is
that important because those things are
going to change under a climate change
scenario how do we check whether this
works where you can run all the standard
tests and the best test without doubt
are to take some of your data and set it
aside Rios timate your models take those
models estimate for the
data that you've set aside and see how
good your predictions are compared to
what actually happened okay always the
best way to test anything you look at
the standard test they work really
really well actually a better test is
the human eye it's better than any R
squared anything else the human eye
picks up patterns much better and
actually still works pretty well they
still think it's about the toughest test
you can give to a model and it still
works pretty well there's two land uses
coming out pretty nicely because we know
we can predict for other periods what we
can nail do is reassemble all the data
re estimate it and they'll say well what
happens when something changes and the
thing that everybody's really interested
in of course is climbing so what happens
when climate changes and climate is
going to change quite significantly
across the UK you can see up there
rainfall it's actually going to get
drier during the growing season
temperature thank God it's actually
going to get warmer so what will this do
to farming well it'll change the pattern
of farming quite dramatically out to the
future this is colored with green being
increases and red being decreases and if
we see here across this bottom layer a
crop called oilseed rape I don't know if
you have it over here but it likes drier
conditions and you can see all that
green coming up as the future gets drier
and warmer quite a number of areas
currently used for dairying will
actually become less suitable because of
exactly the same factors area it's
getting drier warmer less suitable for
pasture what's this mean in terms of
these scenarios the scenarios very not
only climate they also chair very what's
happening in
policy this is a map of income across
farms at the moment and I don't if you
know the UK at all but basically all the
green areas are nice lowland areas often
with very good soils and so you getting
very high values the sort of orange e
area over what am i doing I'll sit this
area over to wear it hope there that's
Wales upland area so it's lower values
there uplands here really high uplands
up in Scotland very low values what's
going to happen in the future when we
get different policies going off and
also climate change well under the world
market scenario most of this map is
green and remember green is good it
means that the values are going up
whereas under the nature at work
scenario where there's an emphasis on
all ecosystem services actually this
constraints on agriculture and we get
you getting some reductions in
agricultural values in this world so
using the old style of making decisions
you just look at market prices there is
no doubt which will do you would go for
you would go for the world market
scenario and that's basically what how
decisions have been made all of our
lives basically we look at market prices
and that's what we do and when we look
at this world and you know the
environmentalists get some control look
what happens they go and mess it up and
we don't get as much food producers we
could do but of course there are other
things coming out of this one the nice
aspects of what it was done in the Naas
linking those land use models to other
models for example hydrological models
so here you've got a model which says
well as land use changes it's going to
have an effect on which crops are
our own and that's going to have big
impacts on water pollution and you can
see there those purple ones that's sugar
beet massive amounts of nutrients going
into waterways particularly towards the
end of the autumn where as switching to
low intensity pasture much lower
pollution levels which of course then
translates into different levels of
ecological status and one of the nice
things about the NEA model is that you
can cycle it round and you can keep
nudging policy changing land use and
changing water quality and ecological
status but so what okay down here we're
going to get more scum on the water you
trick a shin up there we're going to get
more newts and salmon so what well is
there a value attached to that one of
the things that we did was to see
whether there was any relationship
between environmental quality and
recreational values so sampled a large
and diverse area when people's homes
recorded where they live on a GIS
recorded where they visited link that
subsequently to naturally available day
set on water quality back from the
survey find out how often people go to
these places and hopefully you should
realize that we now got all the
information we need to conduct travel
cost analysis so we can work out whether
there is any association between water
quality and visitation and therefore the
value and lo and behold actually when
you control for all the other things
that get British people to rivers
notably very highly significant was
whether there's a pub on the river but
once you control for that you do find
that people go more to cleaner rivers so
we do care you can apply these
models across the whole of Britain so
here you've got a model here in pure
quantity terms how many visits were made
in different places not surprisingly it
mimics where people live there's London
as Birmingham where I'm from Liverpool
Manchester Glasgow Edinburgh it's just
what you'd expect and you can move from
that using those sort of models to
actually working out the value of
recreation and one very simple thing
they shows you is it's a really good
idea to improve environments near to
where people live so it's really
blindingly obvious but unfortunately if
you look at most EU policy it makes no
concession to where people live at all
so it's just as likely that they'll
improve rivers in the middle of nowhere
as rivers that go through the middle of
towns what's the consequence of these
different worlds remember the world
markets one well the world markets one
is one where we really go for
agricultural intensification and if you
do that you're actually going to lower
values in many areas particularly those
areas around cities where at the moment
a lot of agricultural areas are
preserved for recreational access if you
go for the nature at work world
everything looks a lot better other
values greenhouse gases brought in
models of carbon fixing brought in
models of carbon release because
obviously plants fix carbon but then
they release it so these are emission
graphs for the usage of in this case
timber makes a big difference how you
use those different products soils it
really matters what sort of soil you've
got and what usage it's under and where
it is all of these things affect the
amount of carbon storage and the net
change that
kurz between different scenarios corsa
obvious one is machinery but also other
inputs like fertilizers fertilizers are
produced using very heavily
energy-intensive processes so all that
is captured in the model and finally
these ladies are sort of making their
own crusade for global warming and
therefore we need to count exactly what
they're doing do all that bring it all
together and you find that different
scenarios generate very different levels
of carbon emissions which of course you
can value using methods that I'm sure
other people have told you about so
there's the world markets one nail
things don't look so good all nastily
red whereas nature at work a lot of it's
nice and green last thing that I'm going
to consider in terms of money is urban
green space lots of studies of urban
green space they all basically come up
with the same very obvious result that
the closer you live to something like a
an urban park on average when you
control for everything else that will
give you a higher house price the
interesting to do that to cross
culturally actually I'm not sure that
that necessarily always works in the US
but definitely over in Britain that's
the relationship you get and you can
take that relationship and extrapolate
it for different scenarios again across
Britain and in world markets we lose a
lot of urban green space and nature at
work we actually gain urban green space
that's why you've got green values here
red values over there we can now put all
of these values together these are the
initials of the six scenarios doesn't
matter what they are we're only just
focusing on these end to ones here so
we've got nature at work and world
market remember the agricultural story
if we just look at market values then
nature at work stinks it actually is
worse
the present day that's why I've colored
it red whereas will markets is fantastic
nice green color cuz it looks a lot
better than the present day actually the
second highest net present value that
you get out of any of these scenarios it
looks really good but that's just
considering one aspect of each system
services provisioning and we now know
there's loads of them as carbon and
Recreation all those other ones oh there
and what's more they all change
spatially and they change again under
different scenarios so your massive
change available to you now let's go
back to that situation and add in all
those are the values and you can see the
result completely flips on its head
actually world markets is bad for the UK
hope for UK plc it actually generates a
net value which is worse than the
present day whereas nature at work comes
out with the highest value if you're
interested all these results are on the
web and instead of just this simple
ranking you've actually got the monetary
numbers attached to each one of them
other things you can do with this you
can take value maps so here's one of an
area of Britain Wales and you can say
what would happen if we changed from
agriculture which dominates the country
to woodland well you'd lose all this up
here its farming value and if you're
just doing a market analysis this is all
you gain in terms of timber you'd never
do it and that's why I Wales is
completely covered by farming there's
virtually no woodland left there at all
but there's massive carbon benefits
associated with woodlands and there's
massive recreational benefits when we
stick all those values together we find
that actually huge areas of the country
should be under woodland if we actually
counted all the values equally
particularly down here near cardiff and
swansea a lot of people living down
there massive recreational values say
more pee because got people coming in
from liverpool and manchester that
contrasts that map but you saw before
with where forests actually are you see
there's massive amounts of forestry here
in almost exactly the wrong place in
fact they've actually forested quite a
lot of peatlands why because the market
price of peatlands is really really
cheap but from a system service point of
view it's a disaster because actually
when you stick trees on Pete you
actually dry the Pete's out and they
emit huge amounts of carbon far more
than they still would by the trees so
you actually got global warming forests
in Wales want to finish off by extending
this analysis to biodiversity great I
already said the some aspects of the use
value of biodiversity that I think you
can value fairly readily in fact I think
the big problem is the science so
pollination the problem is not the
valuation it's actually understanding
the relationship between say bees and
production which is not easy however
what about Owen I think you can look at
recreation and by adversity as fine as
well these these are all use values what
about non use values I'm sure you come
across these how do you assess them well
they typically assessed using stated
preference methods as I said I've done a
lot of stated preference work and I
think it's absolutely following to ask
people questions about things that they
know about but biodiversity is not one
of those things and so I'm really pretty
convinced that it's not a good thing to
ask people about just to illustrate this
is a solid study that we did recently
looking at how much people in Britain
are prepared to pay
for unique and non unique animals that
they're never going to encounter in the
cameroon highlands and in the Eastern
art mountains of Tanzania we did ask the
law you have you have been there and are
you ever likely to go there and one
hundred percent said no to both
questions so these are pure non-use
values so we asked them about these are
choice experiments you know what choice
experiments are looks very technical but
basically you're still asking barmy
questions we said you know how much for
the line how much for 13 frogs and they
gave us some amount and then at the
other extreme we went to instead of one
site we've got two sites now and there's
more frogs so really really should be
better but you get exactly the same
values you get complete non scope
sensitivity to these questions basically
people are just saying please leave my
house I will say any number that gets
you out the door of course if we go to
them and say well but what about 20
frogs and a gorilla and and its unique
you know in this area if you get rid of
it there's not no gorillas like this
anywhere else then people say oh that's
I'll give you a bigger number for that
so basically we love things like
gorillas but we have no sensitivity to
some of the vital species which make up
the food webs which actually make places
viable for creatures like gorillas so
two questions do stated preferences
reflect the state of illness to pay
using these methods reflect people's
preferences possibly they do people want
to protect carries met it unique piece
species but whoops but are these
preferences a good basis for making
sustainability policy absolutely not
because there's no sensitivity to
anything that is not big and furry
with big brown eyes and therefore no
concept of food webs and actually that
you yet you do have to have the horrible
slimy stuff in order to get the big
brown eyes stuff so I don't believe that
we can rely on these non use values for
biodiversity what then should we do
should we give up as economist
definitely not I think we can pursue a
more sophisticated approach to cost
effective provision of existence of
species and I finish with this case
study from Sumatra so Sinatra is a
absolutely amazing place you get these
incredible species there pangolins
Tigers cm Ang's but there is an
ecological wow it actually is too late
say there's an ecological disaster going
on it's already happened there most of
the place has gone already you see these
sort of statistics they are not in a
raid amount they're really pretty grim
the real force that's happening here is
loss of habitat so we were extremely
lucky we got in with a business group in
central Sumatra I'm not allowed to tell
you exactly where it is but they
basically almost allowed us to take over
a major plantation for four years when I
say take over they operated it but they
we were on site there was somebody on
site from the group the whole time they
completely opened the books to us they
allowed us to do a variety of ecological
experiments they're seeing what would
happen if you tore down tiger fences
what would happen if you didn't put
poison around the area a lot lots of
different experiments like that those
are written up in a variety of papers
but I'm going to talk about
an economics analysis that we did there
so this is the plantation or rather it's
the concession you can see the boundary
of the concession is all the colored bit
the yellow part is areas that are
intensively cultivated for palm oil red
is the roads so as I say they opened up
their books to us we throughout the
period monitored all of the revenues
that they were getting in the costs that
they were paying and in the end we end
up with a data set of about two and a
half million records for the period all
of it spatially referenced and that
allows you to do some interesting things
for one thing you can work out the fact
that the costs of conservation which of
course are primarily was there's two
elements one is preparation of land for
conservation that's generally fairly
minor but the big cost is profit for
gone and you can find out that the
opportunity cost of of conservation is
very definitely not constant and
actually that information is going to
drive at least half of this analysis so
the costs are not constant what you find
is that rhapsodizing wrong one the costs
are highest near to the milling plant
why is that well it's obvious because
the cost of getting the stuff the palm
oil to the plan are very low then they
always of course that the the costs are
always really high in any area that is
already planted when you're looking at
an area that's a long way away from the
plant and isn't currently under palm
then the costs are much much lower you
don't have to make roads so you can cost
saving there
you're not destroying existing crops
that sort of thing so lots of
heterogeneity in the cost side which is
going to be very helpful what about the
effectiveness of conservation how many
animals are you actually going to create
in effect by moving land into
conservation either an almost data
gathering exercise thousand kilometres
of transits were walked over the period
every time an animal was seen it wasn't
me doing this because I wouldn't know
one from another these were trained
ecologists they said what it was and
recorded using a GPS where it was that
data was then fed in through a GIS and
could be related to the conditions of
the area these are the sort of animals
that were there wonderful animals like
the leopard cat absolutely gorgeous
considered of no value whatsoever which
I think reflects the absurdity of
people's preferences basically there's a
lot of these they considered the rats of
the jungle and so nobody cares the same
thing about the pig although the pig has
one very very useful purpose in that
it's the main food of the tiger which we
did actually have on the site but not in
not in sufficient numbers to do a study
what we did have insufficient numbers
was lots of things on the iucn red list
like cute guys like pangolins absolutely
lovely and also on the red list lots of
eight so Apes monkey I can never
remember which one it is Gibbons pull
all this data together and you can begin
to get some relationships some spatial
relationships I could talk through that
is quicker to actually just do this and
say there's the map of the plantation
and here is the suitability
of land conversion for conservation and
basically the green areas are the areas
where if you convert these you'll get
lots and lots of animals in convert the
red areas you won't and really it's you
know occasionally I tell my mom about
what I do and she looks at stuff like
this and says they pay you to do this
it's really obvious basically it's a
good idea to convert land next to
primary forest well I do get paid for it
so anyway that's fine everybody's happy
but lots of heterogeneities again so I
can take that and I can reintroduce the
heterogeneity in the cost side as well
and now I can do a cost-effectiveness
analysis which basically means just that
which of the areas which deliver the
best conservation at the lowest
opportunity cost and it's these darker
areas down here obviously well away from
where the mill was and obviously near
the the forest but there is a question
there is quickly
yeah it absolutely would be sensitive to
it it's also sensitive to where the
roads are and that's hardly surprising I
mean you see these dreadful studies of
what's happening in Brazil what's been
happening for 20 years in brazil roads
are killers once you've got a road
that's where it all fans out from so
everything spatial that's what we as
economists have got to catch up on you
know where it is really really matters
yeah so thanks is it enough so we looked
at here's a there's three different
sizes of reserve that you could
establish within the within the
concession concessions pretty big it's
about 40,000 hectares so you could have
a 5,000 I don't know why we came up with
these numbers I'm sorry they now look
really weird to me but I'm sure there
was a reason it was the ecologist that
came up with these numbers i'm sure i'd
have gone for 5 10 and 20 but anyway
these are the numbers of these different
these are all readily species the ones
in the box are sufficient the ecologist
tell me to be a viable population on
their own they could actually lasts and
breeding and keep going and so that
that's pretty amazing that actually even
with the 55,000 you've got viable
populations for most of them when you
get to the 11,000 all of them have hit
viability okay all right yeah I should
have said there is a whole lot of
institutional stuff going on at the
moment on certification to actually make
this happen there's still a problem
though why should a
producer do this even though you know
we've made it incredibly cost effective
we minimize the cost for that for them
and maximize the amount of biodiversity
given that cost why should they do it
well there's no reason why should they
reduce their profit at all well as a guy
here who isn't here okay I was going to
be nice to him he's not here Matt cotton
has done quite a lot of study on work on
this stuff it's rubbish no it's really
good stuff car passes on video damn okay
it's really really good especially is
papering gapa looking at how you might
get people compensated for this stuff
you got real problems you can't stick
the money through the government
absolutely not totally corrupt that's on
video as well I want voluntary schemes
well people around there just can't
afford it but there are people in
developed countries that are interested
in paying extra amounts for goods that
are chemically physically absolutely
identical but produced in different ways
so we undertook experiment back in the
UK looking at people's preparedness to
buy different products which were
identical in all ways apart from the
fact that they were labeled as coming
from plantations like this one that were
actually undertaking conservation
friendly activities and what we found
was that you could actually get a price
premium from this as there's a paper if
you're interested in a journal called
Oryx which I realize I haven't put up
showing that actually you can move this
premium around quite a bit by the way
you present this but a 15-percent
increase was really quite robust so if
you go into conservation
you're going to incur costs even if we
minimize them they're still going to be
more costs than you were bearing before
so the question is does the fact that
you can then label your product as
conservation friendly increase your
revenue to the extent that your profit
actually goes up or not well the answer
is yes if you go for the smallest
conservation zone 5001 okay then
actually the costs that you incur a
small enough relative to the revenue
increase that you actually increase your
profit you actually ate more money going
into biodiversity friendly production
they're not so no longer do you have to
rely on excitations to companies to be
nice which are Percy think is a complete
waste of time and I'm not saying that to
say that companies are nasty they are
mandated to make profits now what you
can do is you can turn it into their
self-interest to actually get into
conservation these companies are run by
people just like you and me they would
like to do nice things but they're
mandated not to but if you can make it
profitable to them suddenly you can
actually see conservation pay that's the
way that really i think this shirt
should be done i'm conscious that we're
just about out of time i was going to
talk where are you sure okay i was good
i was going to finish off very quickly
by talking about payments for existing
services the cost side two types cost
regulation costs very important
opportunity cost miller talk more about
that because that's really the focus of
payments freak system service research
and just to illustrate that there is a
problem back to the UK so we've got a
case study here in the air catchment
very diverse again
there's a problem that the air itself is
pretty polluted nutrients from farms in
particular leading to very high levels
of you JK Shin I'm not saying you can
walk across the river but it's pretty
grim and it's a very important river
because it goes right through leaves and
Bradford's there's a lot of people where
that would benefit from having a clean
River as we've shown any other studies
you can look at a variety of ways of
tackling the problem and the interesting
thing is that the problem can be tackled
in ways which have different
effectiveness in terms of how well they
reduce pollution and very different
costs those are millions of pounds
inside a relatively small catchment per
annum so the cost effectiveness in other
words the pounds per milligram of
nutrient reduced is very very different
according to which way you go did the
same thing for who as well so if we want
to go from this situation here to this
situation there there's going to be
course will be benefits where we apply
the approach that we did before and
actually turns out the benefits are much
larger than the cost but who's getting
them is not the same people so the
benefits are basically to the open
community over here the the costs are to
the farming community up in the top of
the catchment so there's a an equity
issue we want to try and induce these
farmers into ecosystem service scheme so
what are their characteristics of an
ideal payments for ecosystem service
scheme well it's virtually last night I
think first of all they have to be
incentive compatible and I don't know to
what extent you've been introduced to
the ideas of mechanisms which are
actually making in the interests of the
person concern to actually tell the
truth
have you done anything on this no that's
a real shame but it's really cool I mean
for example a very simple way in in a
lab I say you know gives this bottle of
fine wine how much are you prepared to
pay for it and you're all thinking well
you know i love that wine it's
absolutely fantastic but i'm going to
say a dollar okay and then i say oh by
the way i've actually got a mechanism we
might be a roulette wheel or something
like that and i'm going to chuck the
ball in it and a price is going to come
up okay so it's a random mechanism and
if you've bed an amount lower than that
then you're not going to get the wine if
you've big an amount higher than that
you're going to get it and you're going
to pay the price that the roulette wheel
says and you think about that what's
your optimal strategy or your optimal
strategy is to tell the truth suppose
that your truth is ten dollars you love
this one it's absolutely fantastic it's
what you want and you think you're going
to be strategic and you say huh six okay
and the roulette wheel comes up eight
where you don't get the wine and if
you'd have told the truth you would have
got it for eight dollars so you can see
there's actually a lot of very simple
ways to induce people to tell the truth
once you've worked it through them with
them once they see something you
pondering over that one take it home and
think about it you actually have no
choice but to tell the truth so you use
incentive compatible situation you don't
do we've got this huge collaboration
with this water company they've given us
about half a million dollars to play
with and we're working with these
ecologists oh they're lovely people but
they said oh we've come up with this
great idea we're going to get all the
farmers together in the whole catchment
and we're going to get them in a pub and
we're going to buy them a couple of
pints and then say tell us the truth all
right tell us the truth how much do you
need to stop using fertilizers
we're just like no that's not like we
can do it honestly you do the ecology
wheel to the economics that's not the
way we're going to do it so you use
these sort of mechanisms and you can get
really good results another real twist
to that is to make these payments for
ecosystem services partly dependent on
outputs nearly all schemes in the EU I
don't know about the American situation
our input based they say right if you
put a load of land into biodiversity
habitat we will give you this payment
well that's actually not what we want we
don't want land we want biodiversity we
don't want you to say right this area's
I'm going to change how I'm farming this
area for say water what we want is clean
water so it's not the inputs that matter
it's the outputs that matter so what you
want to try and do is actually
incentivize them also in terms of the
output so you actually say for example
if in your area you can actually produce
three breeding pairs of lapwings which
is something that's very interesting
mounting in Britain you will get a bonus
on top of the guaranteed payment you
will get a bonus now what will that do
to farm as well farmers are the people
better than anybody else better than
economists even but also better than
ecologists at knowing their land they
will know just how good their land is
for different types of activity and
they've actually probably got a pretty
good idea of how good it is for wildlife
and therefore if I'm a farmer and that
knows that I can actually produce these
sort of wildlife outputs that you are
interested in I know that I'm going to
end up with a higher payment than my
neighbor therefore I'm actually prepared
to actually go into contracts more
readily
somebody who can't produce those outputs
in other words it will attract in just
the people that we actually want when
we've got limited funds so you stick
those two things together and then you
just do very simple changes in the law
like this thing with the water company
all the water companies up until last
year they had they were mandated to
clean up water okay still mandate is
clean up water but up until last year
they could only do that through
treatment works now they can do it by
paying farmers not to pollute in the
first place simple little rule change
like that and suddenly payments freak
system services become relevant to the
private sector okay conclusions things
in Britain have not been particularly
amazing over the last sort of 5060 years
actually they weren't that fantastic
before that but that was outside our
period some things are beginning to pick
up you can use some useful analyses
mainly motivated so that decision makes
understand it by things like scenario
analyses and actually show that most of
the existing services we're interested
in can actually be valued non-use
biodiversity values remain a problem but
I believe that we can go a lot further
by more sophisticated spatially
referenced cost-effective in that
analyses and I also believe that there's
a lot of room to improve and incentivize
the private sector to get involved with
things like payments for ecosystem
services if you're interested there is a
new network admittedly based in Britain
but you know the electricity goes right
the way across the Atlantic you could
selling up to this is completely free
the this was launched first of January
the first two years were intended to get
natural scientists social scientists
especially economists and policymakers
together so far we've got I think 127
institutions already signed up for this
hundreds of members from all over most
of them a research but I've got a lot of
policy makers in there and increasingly
we got private sector in the second
phase of it there will be a big
expansion towards the private sector as
well second phase starts into next year
thanks very much for listening dunno if
we've got time for questions but I
really appreciate the chance to come and
talk to you